allez on va on part à londres maintenant
avec une campagne de sensibilisation à
l'allaitement campagne qui fait
polémique et ses 28 minutes
darty qui nous était pour quelles
raisons couvrez ce sein que je ne
saurais voir sans doute que certains
londoniens ont eu cette réplique de
tartuffe en tête lorsqu'ils ont
découvert quatre singes ig en test aux
quatre coins de la ville c'est sain qui
sont installés sur les toits de londres
ont laissé bon nombre d'habitants bouche
bée mais c'est surtout une campagne de
communication pour l'allaitement en
public car le ms préconise l'allaitement
du nourrisson pendant les six premiers
mois de l'année et malgré cette
préconisation elles sont nombreuses à ne
pas oser le faire déjà par pudeur et
puis aussi par crainte et par compte du
regard des autres
alors que la loi en tout cas en france
et dans bien d'autres pays l'autorisent
pleinement
d'ailleurs selon une récente étude même
un sondage la moitié des femmes qui
allaitent disent parfois le faire en
cachette dans des lieux inappropriés
comme les toilettes le alors qu'est ce
qu'on pense de cette campagne de
sensibilisation à l'allaitement qui fait
polémique
parce qu'aussi il ya certains qui ont
une deuxième lecture et qui disent c'est
encore une façon de faire une sorte d'
injonction aux femmes en disant si vous
n'allez pas vous aider mauvaise mère
parlait pas avoir de deuxième lecture
c'est hyper gonflé d'avoir fait ça est
très malin et très choc
si le seul message à retenir c'est quand
on a un enfant quand on est une femme on
a le droit d'arrêter dans un lieu public
sans que l'on se prenne réflexion sans
que vous soyez choqué messieurs même
sens que vous voyez pardon mais dans ce
geste qui est vital un truc sexuelle ou
un truc y avoir au moins un truc mal
élevé ou un truc qui est gênant pour
vous dans ces cas là tu leur tout de
suite tu te détourne le regard ou sans
ballon à la personne ben oui bah oui
mais je vais quand même dérange oui ça
me dérange du pays marandais liens et
fabien en l'accusant alors je sais que
je vais me faire lapider par les
féministes sur les raisons et voir une
femme qui allaitent en public ça me
dérange ça me gêne pourquoi parce que
pour moi le sang appartient l'intimité
de la femme et doit recouvrir une
certaine pudeur
voilà c'est juste que c est ce qu une
femme qui allaite est pour vous un
pudique et ce qu'elle peut le est-ce
qu'elle peut le faire aussi dans un
resto dans un système un type de façon
un peu sobre sans être mais toussaint
dehors là sa bouche est effectivement il
ya effectivement plusieurs situations
qu'on peut on pourrait voilà faire
affaire l'état mais effectivement si une
personne fait ça en plein milieu
tramway en l'air de dire ces voix là je
milite je montre que j'allais amis sont
dits safa mais il ya aussi la question
parfois derrière tu le sais bien
et je suis désolé comme mon roman
d'intervention banon parfois ça peut
être de la première et je suis désolé
aujourd'hui en 2019 c'est très compliqué
de savoir comment tu te comportes face à
une femme qui allaite si tu regardes tu
peux vite tomber dans la catégorie des
pervers qui a qui harcèlent et puis en
même temps on la santé mentale un petit
peu bizarre
et si tu dénonces le regarde on cassera
un anti féministe et qui sera
complètement récupéré pour l'apa droit
d'exhiber le sale en public
donc je suis désolé ça crée un malaise
et il existe aujourd'hui des appareils
comme les tirs les par exemple qui
peuvent justement là là mais c'est pas
plus vive et non à l'aise le malaise des
quotas
à chacune de ses interventions le
malaise c'est damien canivet d'accord tu
sais on veut pas être d'accord mais
c'est juste ma les ans et ça a paru
maintenant d'en questionner zen dans le
discours de diamal damien on peut
entendre que je peux l'emmener s'agira
comment se compléter l'entendra mais
malheureusement son discours ne jugent
son discours me traite d'un pudique jean
messier
tu l'as dit que c'est un pudique et
comment se comporter quand elle sort son
sein mais mon gars gardent pas c'est pas
toi qu'elle va nous rien que ces sondes
et même moi je préfère passer
d'entreprise et c'est là où ça devient
gênant parce que malheureusement des
gens aux esprits un petit peu mal tourné
comme damien pense le sein s'est tout de
suite un argument de sexuel un truc
provocateur alors que de base ben c'est
justement le rouge alors que diane
sûrement des ralliés léon journal a en
l'occurrence il ne il ne sert pas de
pulsions sexuelles dayez il serre la vis
elle était en train de faire tourner
qu'ancien au restaurant la dame mais
attendez c'est comme ça qu'il n'est pas
moi même si j'ai un organe qui serre la
vis et je ne le montre pas
et non mais
si ma part ailleurs d'abord dix minutes
après je me pose une autre question de
prix mais sur ceux sur ce sujet si alors
moi je ne vois pas d'injonctions des
femmes à allaiter je pense que
l'allaitement alors c'est une liberté
mais c'est aussi un droit de l'enfant
quand même l'enfant a le droit d'être
aligné donc il n'y a pas de mal à
inciter les femmes à allaiter c'est
parce que finalement c'est que ça reste
plus meilleur pour l'enfant que les
biberons ratifié le même s'il ya aucun
problème maintenant sur cette campagne
je suis pas sûr qu'on sensibilise
vraiment les gens à l'allaitement avec
ça le principal obstacle à l'allaitement
sait que c'est compliqué que c'est
difficile c'est fatigant faut se
réveiller la nuit l'enfant dort moins
bien les nuits sont plus courtes et ce
qui est compliqué ici c'est le retour au
travail
lorsqu'on a un congé maternité de moyens
et qu'il faut remettre au travail et
bien derrière il faut c'est peut-être ça
le travail c'est là où il faut mettre le
paquet sur la place de la femme dans la
société plutôt que sur mettre un saint
ou que des gens à me malere par ailleurs
c'est parce que il ya aussi une seconde
lecture un peu plus insidieuse de ces
féministes qui montre ses seins géant
etc qui voudraient de nous dire que bah
si vous n'arrêtez pas votre enfant c'est
que vous êtes une mauvaise mère et que
vous ne faites pas les choses dans les
règles de l'art est ce que là dessus
non mais ça c'est différent mais moi je
peins d'après ce que j'ai vu ce que j'ai
lu ce que j'ai entendu c'est pas le
propos là c'est vraiment plus le sein en
tant que telle n'a évidemment se prend
un peu dans pleine poire donc on est un
petit peu choqué il est juste ça en fait
le message n'a rien à voir avec le fait
que l'on doive elles étaient ou pas ça
franchement c'est vraiment à chaque
femme de de choisir et de voir que
d'accord voilà vous avez pris le sac
plein de poireaux alerte on met d'accord
voilà
non mais c'est exactement ça et
finalement on est plutôt d'accord c'est
que moi ce qui me choque
non mais faut chérir et n'avait pas mis
rapidement à chaque effectivement c'est
ce sens en pleine poire comme tu le dit
et on peut mettre un vêtement le faire
de façon discrète vu qu'on n'a pas
besoin bien sûr on est d'accord dit
pardonnez moi mais il ya peu de sa femme
tina blouin dehors en train d'aller
perdre jura petit un petit linge sur le
visage de l'enfant lors sans même bouger
la conclusion valley rob ruygh voûté
nous la paix tu dis on dit ça damien et
lâchez nous laissant voilà très bientôt
tout à fait d'accord
[Applaudissements]